sometimes vegas knows something that we
don't sometimes vegas is just flat out
clueless fanduel sportsbook has updated
odds for cam newton's next team and the
patriots are the favorites at minus
190
aka bet 190 to win a hundred they're the
only team in negative territory the
jaguars plus 300 bet 100 win 300
steelers plus 750 broncos plus a
thousand bears plus eleven hundred
raiders plus fifteen hundred washington
plus fifteen hundred chris of all those
you know which one i would take i would
take the steelers you know why i i
i i'm not convinced ben ross's
roethlisberger has not entered the
territory of his of his life cycle where
his body is going to continue to break
down and i might i think that i think
that at this point at this point your
best play if you're cam newton is to
wait and of all the quarterbacks out
there the the one most likely to get
injured and create the opening and the
need for cam newton is ben
roethlisberger yeah i i mean i you know
listen mike i think it's a good thought
i i certainly as i sat here and looked
at these teams
you know if you're pittsburgh you'd love
to have cam newton as that insurance
policy certainly but you know if you do
bring him there
i i don't think that's gonna make big
ben feel you know very happy it's gonna
it could cause issues which then could
cause disrupt your football team and you
know cause us to look at them you know
in a dysfunctional way you know again
like the antonio
antonio brown situation you know listen
i still want to sit here and go
why did the bears not sign him to begin
with i still don't understand that if i
was the bears i would have called cam
newton and and said hey we'd like you to
be the quarterback i still look at
jacksonville i'm going to take
jacksonville i don't think new england
first off like you said vegas can be
wrong you know they had tua going to the
detroit lion so they they don't know
everything all right that was stupid on
vegas's part and i think it's stupid to
say he'll go to new england new
england's big into framing their
football team i think if they wanted to
do cam newton they would have drafted
players that fit cam newton's style of
play and and i just don't see that
happening so i'm going to say
jacksonville is my leader in the
clubhouse here
and you know there was something
up with this possibility that the
jaguars would have taken tua if they had
the chance even though we've been led to
believe they're all in with gardner
minshew the second so
let's see let's see what happens with
minshu maybe newton is a guy that they
have in their back pocket
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports